j'ai pris la décision aujourd'hui
d'annoncer ma retraite et reggae s'est
rendu à l'évidence
à 37 ans et n'est plus prêt à mettre sa
vie en danger à 150 km heure sur des
pistes glacées loin de sa famille car
peut-être plus à la bonne place donc
c'est est temps de passer à autre chose
j'accepte les risques quand je
compétitionne pour les podiums mais en
ce moment mon ski pour pas niveau il a
pris sa décision mercredi en haut de la
piste son coéquipier manuel osborne
paradis venait d'être héliporté victime
d'une double fracture à la jambe
en attendant le portillon de départ
j'y ai pensé descendre en télécabine
eric gay est le meilleur skieur canadien
de l'histoire
il est monté sur 25 podiums en coupe du
monde la première fois en 2003 avec
louise là même où il accrochera ses skis
[Applaudissements]
erik guay a remporté un globe de cristal
et a été couronné deux fois aux mondiaux
les tout derniers succès de sa carrière
montre l'étendue de son courage en 2017
ils n'ont deux fois sur le podium du
championnat du monde une douzaine de
jours seulement après une chute
spectaculaire ce qui manquera à son
brillant palmarès c'est une médaille
olympique malheureux quatrièmes à turin
l'option 2 5e place à vancouver à trois
centièmes seulement deux médailles en
super-g
un battement de cils sa carrière a été
minée par les blessures au genou et au
dos qui auront notamment fait rater les
jeux de pyongyang
j'étais très choyé de pouvoir voyager à
travers le monde d'avoir quand même eu
beaucoup de succès à skis et puis en ce
moment je suis en santé
j'ai une belle famille à la maison j'ai
vraiment pas de regrets et léguer
prendre le départ d'une course pour la
dernière fois dimanche à l'épreuve du
super g une descente symbolique
je pense que c'est une bonne place pour
dire au revoir à tout le monde que j'ai
toujours aimé un dernier au revoir avant
de retrouver sa femme et ses quatre
filles qui l'attendent depuis un bon
moment à mont tremblant et si antoine
des réseaux canada montréal
[Musique]